[Music]
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight holy
smokes there is a lot going on in this
country right now wouldn't you our best
over the next hour to explain what is
happening and what it means we're
learning ourselves in a lot of case the
answer to both of those questions so for
almost three years the leadership of the
Democratic Party in Congress resisted
calls from it's politically inflamed
base to impeach President Trump polls
showed little support for impeachment
among actual voters they were skeptical
of it older members in Congress like
Nancy Pelosi remembered well what
happened the last time the opposition
party impeached a sitting president
Republicans did that you remember back
in 1998 and in the end the only winner
in that saga was Bill Clinton himself he
was supposedly disgraced but in fact if
he looked at the numbers he was
politically much stronger than he had
been before he was impeached Pelosi and
not for no reason told college she
worried that impeaching Donald Trump
might just get him reelected and so up
until just last week
impeachment seemed like a fading
prospect and then suddenly out of
nowhere it seemed with little fanfare
and almost no explanation everything
seemed to change tonight just a few
hours ago Pelosi announced that
impeachment proceedings are in fact
underway full steam ahead I can say with
authority the Trump administration's
actions undermine both our national
security and our intelligence the
actions of the trump presidency revealed
dishonorable fact of the president's
betrayal of his oath of office betrayal
of our national security and betrayal of
the integrity of our elections therefore
today I'm announcing the House of
Representatives moving forward with an
official impeachment inquiry I'm
directing our six committees to proceed
with their investigations under that
umbrella of impeachment inquiry the
president must be held accountable no
one is above the law the people who sold
out your country to China are concerned
that President Trump betrayed America's
now as of this moment closest party
seems to agree there behind her mostly
as Congressman John Lewis of Georgia
explained working to remove an elected
president a year before a democratic
election is in fact somehow a defense of
democracy or something like that watch I
believe I truly believe the time to
begin in peace river season against this
president has come to delay or to do
otherwise would betray the foundation of
our democracy are you confused yet if so
we don't blame you if you left town for
the week and you may be wondering what
the hell is going on
exactly impeachment for years they told
you that Trump was going to be impeached
for colluding with Russia spying for
Putin then it turned out he didn't do
that the story evaporated into dust and
seemed to blow away then just a few days
ago they were grumbling about
impeachment again and they dragged corey
lewandowski remember him they brought up
to Capitol Hill to make their case that
didn't go well at all I said we ask you
is it correct that as reported in the
Muller report on June 19th 2017 you met
alone in the Oval Office with the
president could you read the exact
language of the report sir I don't have
it available to me I don't think I need
to do that and I have limited time did
you meet alone with the president that
date congressman I'd like you to refresh
my memory by providing a copy the report
so I can follow along hey you don't have
a copier with I don't have a copy of the
report congressman do you not have an
independent recollection of whether you
met with the president on that date
Karan so I'm just trying to find in the
mall report where it states that well
you have it in front of you I gave you
the president the page number yeah what
we're on page 90 is it sir
mr. chairman you guys turnt the clock
miss no I don't have to start the clock
what he's filibustering didn't take much
for chairman Adler to collapse live on
c-span pretty embarrassing you'd think
at some point Democrats might just
decide to run a real presidential
campaign in 2020 in beat trial Trump
that way just like in a democracy it
would have to be more effective than
what they're doing now and the numbers
show it as of this morning Donald
Trump's approval rate
was the highest it has been since the
inauguration but no Democrats don't want
to wait until the next election they
want to wait till November politics
takes too long and it leaves too much to
chance the risk of democracy is voters
might not agree with you
Hillary couldn't learn that the hard way
in 2016 and the one thing Democrats
don't want to do is to repeat that
better remove your opponents by force if
you can which brings us to the latest
question of impeachment what exactly is
this about it's more confusing sorry to
laugh in the middle of this we spent all
day trying to figure out what is the
impeachment story it's about Ukraine
it's less than a week old and so you
might be forgiven for not understanding
why would the president be impeached for
a story that the Democrats literally
can't explain what did the president do
wrong we're gonna do our best to tell
you the case that they're making and
honestly as we said it's confusing and
not all that interesting within a
sentence here is what they are saying
they're saying that in a phone call with
the president of Ukraine the president
threatened to delay a four hundred
million dollar military aid package to
Ukraine unless the Ukrainian government
agreed to investigate possible criminal
activity involving Joe Biden's son why
Joe Biden's son well for five years Joe
Biden's son it turns out was paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
year to serve on the board of Ukrainian
gas company why would Joe Biden's son be
on the board of Ukrainian gas company he
had no experience in the energy business
he didn't speak the relevant language he
had no apparently no experience
whatsoever in the region turns out at
that very moment Joe Biden was President
Obama's point man for Ukraine
oh so at a certain point during this
saga the company in question was
investigated and then in 2016 the
Ukrainian prosecutor overseeing that
investigation was fired apparently he
was fired under pressure from then Vice
President Joe Biden now to the layman
that looks a lot like corruption
so what does it have to with the
president being in peace well the
accusation is that President Trump
suggested that that squelched
investigation deserved a second look and
Democrats say that suggestion was an
impeachable offense are you following
this of course there are plenty of other
reasons that the u.s. might not want to
send 400 million dollars to Ukraine
it's a notoriously corrupt country for
one thing what do we get out of it for
another and by the way sending military
aid to Ukraine may plays please the
neo-cons and CNN bill kristol is
strongly for it but it also greatly in
chance increases the chances of conflict
with Russia and of course that would
mean nuclear conflicts potentially
what's the point of that exactly nobody
has bothered to explain why sending 400
million in military aid to Ukraine is in
the interest of the United States
they haven't even thought to explain
that they're too busy yelling about
impeachment and they're doing it with
all the hysterical intensity that has
become the hallmark of the modern left
they have a lot of energy too bad none
of it is focused on the country's real
problems and there are a lot of them we
don't want to go through the same litany
again but we will hit on just a couple
because they're worth mentioning our
national debt is exploding and that
includes credit card debt by the way
personal debt at its highest ever
measured we have a war in Afghanistan
that we can't seem to win or end our
towns outside the big cities are being
decimated and desiccated by opioids and
suicide if you haven't been there drive
through and take a look yourself we have
basically an open border with Mexico
tech companies trying to control our
freedom of speech in many ways our
country is on the wrong track and people
know it
everybody knows it Democrats and
Republicans but instead of trying to fix
any of that Democrats want to spend the
next year explaining and they plan to
explaining why it was perfectly fair for
Joe Biden's ne'er-do-wells son to get
six hundred grand a year from Ukrainian
oligarchs that's totally fine but it's
somehow criminal for Donald Trump to ask
about that
that's the message good luck with that
hard to imagine many voters will be
impressed by it